early on as Emma was filming she had a
kind of hilarious habit of mouthing
along to everyone else's lines as they
said them a stone that may skull stops
you from dying no wonder Snape's after
it which to be honest is a total
Hermione Granger move am I right Olivia
saw not Leviosa but it wasn't hilarious
to Emma this is actually quite traumatic
for me she also had issues throughout
the series with her independence or
rather her lack of one she's talked
about how tough it was to basically have
every minute of all her days mapped out
for her minute by minute and how she
didn't have any control over it so she
was told when she'd be picked up and
brought to the set when to eat and when
there was enough time between shots for
her to use the restroom it got under her
skin so much she seriously considered
leaving the series halfway through the
strain of Fame was another factor and
hers was maybe even worse than Daniel
Radcliffe's in the sense that she had to
deal with a literal stalker a dude
showed up at her school one day trying
to find her and from then on she had to
hire private bodyguards to protect her